in the land of jungles
and caves
night brings out horrors
beyond imagination
lurking in the film
creeping in the shadow
killers that have evolved
to win the nightly game of death
nowhere is safe
not even the city
the jungles of indonesia
a world of beauty
and mystery
as night approaches
the jungle's inhabitants get on edge
because strange creatures emerge in the
dark
as darkness falls the cries of two
million winged predators pierce the
jungle sky
mammals who fly like birds
wrinkle lipped bats
this cave is their dominion
while they only average a foot in length
from wing tip to wingtip
what they lack in size
they make up for in number
millions roost in the darkness of this
cave
resting
and waiting
preparing for dusk
and the chance to feed
so
their ceaseless cries aid them in echo
location
this
sixth sense works like sonar
and they use it
to find their prey
echolocation helps each half-ounce bat
devour around one ton of insects per
year
but the bats are not alone in their
caves
others have been waiting for this moment
water monitors
these massive lizards are usually most
active during the day
but the ones in this cave have learned
of the bat's schedule
waiting every night for their flying
neighbors to
take to the sky
water monitors can grow over six feet
long
making them the second largest lizard
species in the world
they patrol this lake of guam
which the bats overhead drop a ton into
every month
the pool of filth doesn't deter the
lizards
who are considered one of the most
intelligent reptiles on the planet
and they are here for one reason
with millions of bats in a frenzy
accidents are bound to happen
every stroke this bat takes
alerts the monitors to his position
his only hope for survival
reaching shore before these hunters
reach him
it's the first bat to fall tonight
the killing has only begun
falling into a lake of guano is a death
sentence
and only a lucky few make it to shore
but there is more than one way to die in
this cave
even the ground here will eat you
because the nutrient-rich bat guano is
home to trillions of flesh-eating
organisms
cockroaches embrace disease-ridden
environments like this
and the ones in this cave
are hunters
packs of them descend on bats who wander
from the colony
to eat them
alive
with wings weighed down by sticky guano
flying's not an option
but neither is staying on the cave floor
this exhausted female has only one
avenue of escape left
she has to climb
but the risk is worth it
if she can reach the protection of the
colony
she has a chance
but she has a long way to go
reticulated pythons
and white lip pit vipers perch in
silence on the cave walls
to catch unsuspecting prey
to succeed
their timing must be perfect
the slightest miscalculation is the
difference between
life
and death
this python locks onto a
much easier target
so
but the python is too slow
his target disappears back into the mass
of bats
safe within her colony
but as long as knight consumes the
jungle
bats run the gauntlet as they leave to
hunt
the python only has to wait
for the perfect moment
to strike
in an indonesian jungle cave
a gauntlet of snakes wait for the
perfect moment to strike
a flying target
this python constricts its dinner
cutting off the bat's blood flow
and squeezing the very life from it
before swallowing it whole
a meal like this could sustain him for
more than a week
for the bats who survive this deadly
gauntlet
the full moon hanging above the jungle
continues to beckon them
into the night sky
there's still several hours before dawn
and another hunter looks for her next
meal
this asian musk shrew
sniffs the air with her long nose to
find food
and while she's not above scavenging off
the cave floor
she prefers fresh meat
only the jungle outside offers
she can grow to be almost a half foot
long
one of the largest shrew species in the
world
but her large size requires a ferocious
diet
eating up to 60 of her body weight every
night
and right now
a delicious aroma dressed from the
jungle
vampire crabs
name for their bright yellow eyes and
their penchant for nightly hunts
these tiny agile crustaceans will devour
nearly anything on the forest floor
but in the jungle the line between
predator and prey is constantly shifting
the crab's armor provides little
protection against the musk shrews
gnashing teeth
but she must finish a meal quickly
or become one herself
tonight
this owl isn't interested in small
mammals
he specializes in aquatic prey
he's a buffy fish owl
with razor-sharp talons
powerful wings
and a vicious hook beat
he waits for the perfect opportunity to
descend on his prey
on tonight's menu
one of the oddest creatures in the
entire jungle
a slimy slithering hunter
a true fish out of water
the snakehead
a fish who can travel for up to three
days across land
in search of new hunting grounds
but its adventures out of water expose
it to grave risk
and this one's wandered into the wrong
neighborhood
the buffy fish owl locks on
ready to fire like a missile
of shark beat and talons
in an indonesian jungle
a buffy fish owl prepares an aerial
assault
the target
a fish that walks on land
the snake head
snake head one chance of escaping is to
reach the water
so
down blocks the snakehead's path
but he might have bitten off more than
he can chew
this naked is nearly two feet long
and won't give in without a fight
thou art for something a little more
bite-sized
the snakehead slips back into the pond
undetected
another aquatic hunter stalks nearby
for her death is nothing more than a
gang
a gang
she plans on winning
she's a versatile hunter both on land
and in the water
and this is her playground
she's an asian small clawed otter
while known for her curiosity and
playfulness
don't let her cute face fool you
she's one of the deadliest creatures in
the pond
she will spend over half her waking
hours killing and eating
she uses her dexterous paws to hold her
catch in place
while tearing it apart the sharp canines
and mullers
but a small fish won't satisfy her
hunger
she desires something with a little more
meat on its bones
the snakehead escaped the owl
only to land in the center of the
otter's hunting grounds
the otter uses her whispers to detect
think underwater movements
if the snakehead is to survive
it must remain perfectly still
but she has a plan
hoping to spook her prey the artists
upped the pond water
it works
she's car primes
but her mail isn't going down without a
fight
for the snakehead
the night is over
the otter eats quickly
while she feeds she's vulnerable
there are much larger predators stalking
nearby
strange solitary creatures
who will eat almost anything
on the ground
or in the trees
they're unlike anything else in the
animal kingdom
and one
is on the hunt
only four hours until dawn
and in the canopy above the jungle floor
one of nature's most bizarre creatures
is on the prowl
this jungle dweller looks like a
creature of fantasy
with a tail like a monkey
a body like a bear
in the face of a cat
but he's real as can be
he's a binturong
the jungle's bearcat
even though he smells like buttered
popcorn
he is armed with powerful sharp claws
that shouldn't be taken lightly
the otter is not on his menu
but there are plenty of other options in
the trees
life up here can be hard
especially when you're less than a half
a foot long
this gecko can remain motionless for
hours
relying on his camouflaged skin to keep
it hidden
but the bearcat can smell what it cannot
see
this gecko
has one more trick up its sleeve
an emergency escape plan
he can fly
he's a cool flying gecko
a jungle daredevil
as he leaps
flaps of skin on his sides deploy like a
parachute
but this is a leap of faith
he has little control over where he
lands
a deadly tokey gecko occupies this
branch
a giant compared to his smaller relative
the toki won't hesitate to devour his
own kind
the flying gecko has to risk another
leap of faith
not the most graceful landing
but he's escaped the jaws of the tokai
in the binturong
the binturong settles on a piece of
fruit to satisfy its hunger
the cool flying gecko escaped from the
predator's bone
but the forest floor isn't much safer
some armed with sharp tusks
but even with these protections
they're always on edge
these scales belong to one of the most
prolific killers in the jungle
and she's come to feed
the nightly dance with death unfolds in
the jungles of indonesia
home to some of the deadliest predators
on the planet
sunrise is quickly approaching
but there will be more death
before the light of day
fierce competition for food leads to
many unique adaptations
but few compared to those of one of the
most prolific killers in the jungle
the only mammal on the planet
was scales
a penguin
whose armored hide is made of keratin
the same material as human nails
she spends her nights searching for
colonies of insects
that she slurps up with her long sticky
tongue
relying more on her senseless smell than
eyesight
her nose leads her through the jungle
for termites and ants there are a few
creatures more ferocious
it's estimated that a single pangolin
consumes up to 70 million termites ants
and larvae a year
but insects are not the only thing
hiding in these logs
so
a spitting cobra
he sprays venom up to eight feet away
and he aims for the eyes
the cobras venom temporarily blinds the
penguin
she curls into a defensive ball
waiting for the threat to pass
with the cobra gone
she seeks safety
deeper
into the jungle
but a far greater threat lurks in this
dense wilderness
the reticulated python
the longest snake species in the world
this female can grow to be more than 20
feet long
and at that size she could swallow an
adult human
home
she slithers along the jungle floor
searching for her next meal
a moving mass of bone and muscle
she kills by constricting her prey
in powerful crushing hugs of death
she's feared throughout the jungle
but tonight
her appetite leads her to strange new
feeding grounds
in the last remaining hours before dawn
a fierce predator heads into the city
as human populations continue to expand
the boundaries between urban areas
the wild
blur
for this reticulated python the world of
humans provides new opportunities
and dangers
wow
um
stray cats dominate this urban jungle
and our potential prey
so
so
jackpot
a nice cool bath
python soaking water to help shed old
skin
and
her
hydrate
to the spa
places her near a house
with the enticing scent of prey
while the home's human inhabitants sleep
the giant enters for a kill
but people aren't on the menu
she's come here for pest control
disease-carrying rats thrive in urban
environments
and these ones have fattened themselves
on the bounty of human civilization
perfect targets for a giant python
her trip to the city paid off
but with sunrise just moments away
it's time to return to her jungle home
dawn breaks
ending the nocturnal hunt
for those who survived another violent
night in the jungle
it's cold comfort
because here
there is always someone ready to strike
you